we all know that the straw hat's journey
through the grand line
is heavily dominated by violence this
violence is enacted by the various
antagonists and by the cruise battles
against them
being a shonen manga fighting is a
central element in the story of one
piece
and yet out of all the established straw
hats there is only one that
actually embraces this need for battle
and makes it a part of its ambitions and
philosophy
zorro is a fascinating character in many
ways
but it is undeniable that at his core he
is a warrior
as a true swordsman inside destroyed
crew he therefore rightfully holds the
position of the fighter
and yet i think that this position alone
does not satisfy the potential of this
man's unique and complex character
much rather it seems that zorro has been
introduced as the counterpartus captain
that is necessary in order to
successfully reach the top of the pirate
world
i would argue that right from the start
zorro has been luffy's right hand man
making him much more than just a simple
fighter on the crew zorro
is the straw hat's first mate now before
we look at the actions and the
characteristics of zorro that qualify
him for this position
let's first establish what the roles of
fighter and first mate really mean
and what sets them apart there is a
difference between being a fighter
and just being an aggressor it is easy
to push around those who are weaker and
enjoy imposing your power over someone
as you might realize there are many
aggressors in one piece and it is easy
to see
why we detest them so much a fighter is
different
fighting is when it's hard fighting
means going out of your comfort zone
it means not giving up it means hating
to lose but
learning from the experience anyway
fighting doesn't always involve violence
it simply means giving your all for
something by overcoming any obstacle in
the way
zoro without a doubt is a true fighter
he identifies himself by becoming
stronger
fighting for his dream to become the
greatest swordsman in the world
in any situation he gives it his all and
sometimes
even more zorro hates nothing more than
losing
but even in defeat he learns from his
failure and draws motivation
and strength from them but what sets him
apart from for example luffy
who's also a fighter in the very same
sense another meaning of fighting is
that of battle while luffy wants to get
stronger and faces off against
ever-strong opponents his true ambition
is to achieve
absolute freedom becoming strong is
therefore just a necessary requirement
that has to be fulfilled
at heart luffy only fights to resolve
conflict and to help others
zorro is different his ambition to
become the greatest swordsman in the
world
is built on a true passion for combat
his mindset
and worldview are centered around battle
and strength
we do not know how zorro came to think
that way but we only know that he
already strived for strength at a very
young age
while we know that zoro's character is
much more complex than this
it certainly can be said that at his
core he's a person that has built his
life around fighting
in other words zorro is a true fighter
through and through
what then is the position of the first
mate and why is sorrow more than just a
great fighter
usually a first mate is the top officer
on board a ship after the captain
famous examples of this are silva's
rayleigh the first mate of the roger
pirates
as well as ben beckman the first mate of
the red hair pirates
first mates can fill a number of roles
from checking stock to making sure
everyone else is doing their job on the
ship leaving their captain to more
important duties
since they are the second in command
they answer only to the captain of the
ship
essentially the first mate is the crew
member that the captain must put
full trust in and pick very carefully
they are the captain's right-hand man
and if the captain's not at hand the
first mate is the next in line to take
over the captain's job
now as you might be well aware of the
straw hats are no regular pirate crew
the members don't operate as much on
hierarchy and power
as they do on trust loyalty and
friendship towards another
additionally the crew is ridiculously
small especially
compared to any other major player in
the new world based on this one could
make the argument that the position of a
first mate or
any type of officer structure is not
really necessary inside the straw hats
this is also supported by the fact that
no kind of officer role has ever been
officially introduced for any of these
draw heads in the first place
and yet i think that oda has made it
very clear that
zorro is supposed to be luffy's right
hand since the straw heads are
unconventional in many ways
the same goes for the position of the
first mate on our hero's ship
it fulfills another purpose than on
other pirate crews
similar to shanks or roger luffy needs
someone who has a more realistic and
rational view on things than he does
someone that tells him a hard truth or
reminds him of what is really important
based on that some people argue that
nami might also be a good fit for this
role
but the first mate also needs to be
someone that can stand next to his
captain in battle
and invoke a similar level of respect
and authority
especially in the violent and
conflict-rich world of one piece
fighting strength is an important
feature for any captain's right hand
and as we already have established
previously zorro is without a doubt one
of the greatest fighters in the story
so let's look at the other qualities
that zorro has and
why they make him the only true fit for
the position of first mate
what makes him more than just a great
swordsman and a fighter on the crew
zorro is one of the most loved
characters in the show for a reason
while his characteristic 3-style sword
and his cool design
certainly play their part in this for
many people it goes
much deeper than this on the surface he
may seem cold
and distant he is not someone to show an
awful lot of emotion
and is rarely seen joking around with
his crewmates and yet being one of the
main characters in the series we have
learned a lot about zorro over the
course of the years that might not have
been obvious at first sight
so now let's look at three important
personality traits that qualify zorro
for the position of the first mate
the first trait that we will look at is
zoro's strong sense of honor
and loyalty having grown up under the
strict rules of a dojo
zorro has without a doubt developed a
mindset that revolves heavily around the
honor of a swordsman
he refuses to take any action that goes
against this honor
even if it means putting his own life on
the line this was established very early
on in the story
when zorro first faced off with dracul
mihawk his sense of loyalty towards his
captain
his crewmates as well as towards his
ideals is repeatedly shown in various
instances as well
the most drastic example of this is his
sacrifice for luffy on thriller bark
when taking on all of his captain's
damage to protect him from kuma
in other words zoro is the most loyal
and honorable straw hat that has stood
beside luffy from the very beginning
additionally he also strives to uphold
these ideals when
faced with the other member's actions
his appeal towards luffy to not take
back uso without an apology
as well as his criticism of sanji's
decision to leave the crew behind
show how important respect and loyalty
toward his captain are to him
this makes him the only one in the crew
that actively tries to build luffy's
authority
so that his captain's orders are
respected when a critical situation
arises
the second personality trait that is
often overlooked within sorrow is his
kindness and empathy
despite his cold and harsh appearance
zoro actually holds strong ideals of
morality and has a very kind heart
while he would do anything for any of
his crewmates that he values very dearly
he has also repeatedly proven to care
about strangers that are in need of help
he carried a man shot by a celestial
dragon carlos to the hospital to save
his life
and just recently he defended princess
yori and her companion toko against one
of the shogun's assassins in wano
even while fighting another opponent not
only are kindness and empathy
defining traits of this draw-head crew
but zoro also has the power to act on it
and defend his nakama as well as people
in need
he knows what the right thing is to do
and always stands close to luffy to
bring down those who bring injustice to
the world
lastly being a true fighter sorrow has a
certain degree of ruthlessness and
realism that are necessary to survive in
the grand line and that is captain lags
while the straw hats are the heroes of
our story due to their positivity and
caring nature
sometimes they can be seen as nivity
sorrow might very well be the only
member that is able to do what is
necessary to ensure his comrade safety
and survival
unlike some of the members of the crew
zoro does not shrink from the idea of
using deadly force against dangerous
enemies
and is known to have killed even before
joining luffy additionally he also has a
more realistic and darker view of the
world
while luffy's optimism and positive
leadership style have brought the crew
very far on their journey
it is nonetheless important to have a
perspective in the crew
that sees the things as they are in this
sense zorro perfectly completes his
captain by bringing the necessary
seriousness with him that has saved the
straw hats more than once
these three traits honor and loyalty
kindness and empathy as well as
ruthlessness and realism make zoro the
only suitable candidate for the man
standing beside the next pirate king
beside these three characteristics there
is also soros relationship with luffy
as mentioned before zoro would do
anything for his captain
and respect luffy really deeply as the
first member of the crew
he is what really was to roger a partner
that stands side by side with his leader
through every situation
when it comes to any critical situation
luffy and zoro don't need a lot of
communication to know exactly what they
have to do
additionally while zoro might not
officially be his first mate
it's very clear that he's seen that way
from the outside not only does
bartolomeo name him as such
he was also the only member of the crew
that entered the group of the supernova
with luffy
and of course he is the man who will
become the strongest swordsman in the
world